what do you think helped netflix evolve
from shipping dvds to streaming video
over the web
or
helped amazon to predict how much
equipment to buy to meet traffic demands
how do you think nasa was able to
analyze data from the mars rover
curiosity
what would have made it possible for
walmart to become the king of the big
box retailers
and help facebook refresh its mobile app
so rapidly
the answer to all these questions is
devops
the devops market generated 3.36 billion
dollars in 2017 and is expected to
generate
9.4 billion dollars by 2023
devops is helping many organizations to
automate their entire process
the process allows any organization to
create and improve their products at a
faster pace than traditional models
so
now let's understand
what is devops
devops as the name suggests is a
combination of two practices
dev refers to development and ops refers
to operations
devops is not a workflow but a culture
that brings these two teams together the
development team writes codes for new
products security updates and bug fixes
the operations team looks after the
servers and makes sure that the
deployments happen more reliably and
frequently
the main focus of devops is on
integrating these two teams in order to
improve collaboration and increase
productivity by automating the entire
process of software development
devops has several stages and tools to
ensure that all this process is
implemented in the best possible manner
let us have a look at all these stages
with the tools that play a significant
role in that phase
beginning with the development phase
so the first step is to put down a plan
that includes the modules and the
algorithms to be used in the software
and once the plan is finalized it is
developed with tools like git as git
helps in storing all the codes and
different versions of those codes this
is called the version control system
now this code is fetched and made
executable in the next stage that is the
build phase
this phase uses tools like gradle and
maven
after the code is made executable it is
supposed to be tested the next stage
tests the code for any bugs and the most
popular tool used in this phase is
selenium
once the testing is done deployment
comes into consideration and this is
where the work of the operations team
begins in the deployment phase the
product is deployed and this deployed
product is continuously configured to
the desired state the tools that
automate these phases are ansible puppet
and docker
the product from here is continuously
monitored for any failures and the most
common tool that makes it possible is
nagios
the feedback of all the monitoring is
sent back to the planning phase this
process is repeated in continuous cycles
until we reach a satisfactory result
this completes the entire devops cycle
the process of automation from the
planning phase to the monitoring phase
this is what is referred to as the core
of devops lifecycle the integration
phase
jenkins another devops tool is known for
sending the code for build and test and
if this code passes the test
it is further deployed and monitored
let us have a look at some features that
are making industries move toward devops
increased customer satisfaction
improved response time
fewer chances of implementation failure
reduction in it cost
better business agility
higher employee productivity and
satisfaction
faster delivery better release control
frequent software releases
better collaboration among teams
automated server configuration
now when you know so much about devops
you must be curious to know what the
future of devops holds it is quite
evident that devops is on the rise and
it's going to have a long way ahead
there are several fields that devops is
going to be explored in the near future
every organization has started leaning
toward automation so devops is going to
play a major role in new upcoming
organizations
when everything moves toward automation
there will be a need for devops in the
security field
devops framework in ai and ml will help
the devops team to focus on innovation
and creativity by enabling them to
manage the amount and speed of data in a
more efficient way
devops focuses on infrastructure as code
which ensures continuity as all the
processes from building to staging are
configured automatically with no place
for human error
the future of devops will make the
culture more popular there is no
industry that does not want to shift
toward more reliability in deployment
every organization wishes to deliver
their product in shorter durations and
reduce the gap between its development
team and operations team
all these scenarios will take devops to
new heights in the near future there are
organizations that have shifted toward
devops and many are planning to do the
same hence the jobs in the market for
devops engineers are certainly going to
rise in the near future
so when are you planning to master
devops you can begin today with simply
learn's devops certification training
course thank you for watching and stay
tuned to simply learn